[Music]
[Applause]
hey hey we might be drunk folks
happy January are we in January we're in
January all right we're rock man this is
this was a little nasty New York day oh
man the snow last night was beautiful I
woke up and I went outside and it's all
sludge it's like a hangover yes it's a
snow hangover the sludge that's perfect
yeah I'm watching my cat on the window
sill snow is falling with a street light
it's beautiful then you go out today and
it's just it's just [__] jizz and me
miscarriage and placenta I stepped into
placenta it was gross I mean it's
disgusting got to get the boots oh I
think I thought a fart was coming later
later yeah yeah but that sludge is no
joke you got to either stick or don't
stick you can't be in the middle I think
the salt's [__] it up I kind of love
it I mean w I haven't broke out
snowshoes in like I think I wore them
all last year oh they're fun yeah well
the warming the global warming we had a
fun moment last night me and the q's did
uh the comedy dojo and I'm on stage and
I hear beep beep beep beep like from
outside smoke alarm no tow truck and I
go we parked in a
handicap and there only one spot left in
the whole club yeah and he's you know we
arried late and the only spot left was
handicapped so we took it oh yeah think
twice until I see this guy beine out the
[__] door to get the to stop the tow
truck guy turns out it was a salt truck
a but I'm a southern queef I don't know
anything about like my old bit remember
that joke having sex it's like uh
finding a parking spot for a guy for a
woman buying a car it's like Jer a car
yeah Joker yeah yeah there's a spot
there's another spot oh I have to pay
never mind that's a great joke
handicapped hope no one sees this old
school that's a great joke I got to tell
you I went to Community College for a
stint not bragging and uh there was a a
Down syndrome gal who was kind of hot
yeah she had huge cans huge you know
[__] jugs and I got to tell you the
guys were all over really I couldn't do
it did they did they hook up with her I
don't know but they were pretty touchy
feely in the back back
row what the hell she was cute I mean
she had a kill her body she you know she
would eat anything if you put anything
in front of her she'd put it in her
mouth so I mean it was chewing you talk
about her like I talk about
Winnie who's got peanut butter yeah yeah
that's a this is the Down Syndrome
Victoria that was a big story for a
while is it okay is the question that's
the question I think it's like a
spectrum probably right I mean ah true
is is it full Downs or is it partially
Downs is it you have to be the judge I
don't know I mean look I could be wrong
in this I'm just you know well she would
say I want to be treated like an equal
maybe sure did she say that that's I
have it in
writing you wrote it she signed it it
was in a crayon but yeah Mark didn't you
have a Victoria Secret Downs Joe I do I
just said i' I'd go Downs on her you
know easy quick in and out something
else like that too was like uh [__] I
don't remember was it it was a Barbie
Down syndrome one I had something too I
don't remember yeah uh what I like about
win is uh she's up she's like alert she
could just sit down and enjoy the day
but she's like up on her feet in case
anything goes down she's usually asleep
I think I think she'll pass out in a
minute it's a lot of stimulus in here
she's like one of us she's up she's up
for now but right she'll pass out she
sees the mics she's got to be on also
salaku looks like a bulldog so you never
know
if she's
threatened uh I didn't bring it up yet
but uh what happened with your NFL memes
thing oh pretty outrageous pretty
egregious well what they all do that all
those memes people did that I was just
you know I had I had a couple in me I
was like let me tweet but yeah no some
people tagged me so I was like oh I knew
they did it but look the the Jerry Jones
thing a bunch of people could have come
up with it's fine but but they know but
I I was the first to post it I think
that's why it went so hard got like 15K
retweet or maybe more I don't know but
oh look at that that's the chicken parm
you always look me up wrong cuz I feel
like it's always X are you sure
unless no it's you no that's me but I
feel like this happened last time yeah I
stink that one's got 10K what oh that's
a Will Smith joke wait I it's like all
2022 I don't know how to do this wait
that's what I said he doesn't know what
the hell I'm confused samarel X there it
is Boom try twiter oh maybe you got a a
fraudulent account no that's me I think
that was my face same link all right
well this is good pod yeah never mind
all right well either way but what's
cool about the stealing now is is if you
call it out then you get you get some
you get a little blow up from just
calling it out well yeah I I uh I posted
like months ago everyone tagged me in it
because I I wrote uh yeah dude what the
[__] is I don't get why this is uh boy
you might have to edit this out um yeah
well I I tweeted something months ago
was that [__] agent you you can tag
it in probably the guy uh maybe you
can't I don't know the chicken parm or
three no yeah three ve parms we walk
which that's pretty specific
and then he did the same thing but added
capish so so I got tagged in it and then
I I posted another one uh yeah it's a
whatever but it got a lot of posts
because it was quick yeah and then the
Jerry Jones one was uh what was it uh
civil rights oh yeah yeah he hav't seen
been this upset since uh since the Civil
Rights Act and then uh that went pretty
hard and then he posted the exact like
the same wording too so I'm like dude
you know you know I guess like Brown
versus Bor if he did something slightly
different I'll give it to you but like
it was the same wording again so uh I
just posted like both of them side by
side and he was like all you had to do
was say he DMS me all you had to do was
say something and I would have T I
tagged you I tagged you but it's like
that way they tag you where no one can
see it yes exactly you know so I was
like [__] I might responding this dweeb
he know but like I have no respect for
these people they're just [__] you
know they just they're like they're not
they're not like but what bugs me is
that they want credit for being witty
yes they don't if they just posted other
like tank cantra is a good one because
he'll post his own [__] his creative
stuff or and then if he posts your [__]
he'll give you credit yes so like that's
fine right but it just bugs me the fact
that they're like they want it all they
want it all you don't want to do any of
the work but you want all the like wow
you're so clever yeah you're not you're
you poach yes they poach and they still
want the pat on the the back it's
[__] so so I just I look I don't
really care but I just I'll trash him
every once in a while I'll be like
you're a [__] loser and then it come
at you all you had to do is talk to me
or whatever it's like all you had to do
is not steal my [__] and also they've
heard it they know that they know what
they're doing is is uh Shady you just
heard on the Cat Williams podcast you
don't steal yes stop stealing jokes well
you know what makes me sleep better at
night is like the fat
Jew where's he now you know I he was the
biggest thing he was an uncut gems he
was all over the place I'll tell you
where he is he got a [__] Rosé made
and we can't get distribution for Bodega
cat what the [__] is going wrong in the
world Mark I didn't know he had a Ros
now white girl Ros oh that's him don't
buy that [__] that guy stinks he stinks
but I feel like I don't uh I don't hear
about him anymore and I think that's
that's that's how the it all comes out
in the wash baby yeah the fet
you turn coat piece of garbage you
[__] you can't you can't find a TW
sweet you [__] photograph from the
fat you stink salacuse Ben a look she's
out she's down now hey hey there we go
all right glad you got comfortable this
is how is this charming I shot this is
this stop I know but like yeah what's
yeah stop it's Charming look at this
[__] clown and it's like too much the
the covering the balls and we're giving
them too much shine here enough's enough
buffalo sauce
Bill guy stinks all right that guy's
going to steal that and go buffalo sauce
Billy what the hell yeah yeah so I was
just also I was in like kind of a mood
cuz like look we did six shows at the
punchline Philly I I I had great time
cuz look I love Philly crowds but like
it was it was the the ceilings are so
high in the club that it was kind of
tough to like get momentum so I'd get
off stage you ever get off stage and
you're just like mad at yourself sure in
a way where like you just start stuffing
your face with the Green Room candy yes
not like like alcohol won't even fill
the hole you need to like be a child
again yeah well you better take it easy
you're going to be the fat you keep
eating those
Snickers but yeah no I'm with you I've
been there the stress eating and then
there's the stress drinking that's also
bad you know speaking of stress drinking
I sent you what they have in the Green
Room Post this [__] this is pretty cool
they have a curig it's a curig but for
liquor so they have like gin rum
everything look at that I'm making a
bodega Cat Side Car you put in a pod for
the mixer and then you isn't that crazy
how' it taste it was pretty [__] good
oh my God if you get that and a sex
robot you're getting [__] and a
cocktail made for you I say we combine
the two yes let's get two and one yeah
my only critique on this is like it's
cool for like a party probably yeah but
then you like you want one that can make
it's kind of slow kind of slow yeah kind
of like that girl you wanted to [__]
back in the
day also you do I mean let's be honest
you missed this what's that oh yeah how
was that BJ oh pretty good you know you
getting a little Mixology the guy with
the mustache the suspenders uh I like I
like when you're making the drinks I
agree and I like I like making a drink
and that's kind of and I I have in my
rider they have to have
vermouth Bodega cat and Bitters I make a
[__] I like making a drink
backstage but also like even with my
coffee I like to like the something
about the kurg just it doesn't do it for
me sess it's cool it's I enjoyed it but
it is and also it's shitty it's bad for
the environment true the pods will get
you yeah it's sex with a prostitute it's
like getting there it's a sex robot a
prute will still get you there that's
true she's got a history she smells a
certain way there's an accent usually
Eastern block but uh yeah this is the
prostitute still got a personality
that's true she's been through some [__]
and as comedians I relate to them yeah I
just think like the curig just tastes
like [__] anyone I've had people be like
it's good coffee I'm like you [__] I
mean like I I'll drink it like we have
it here I'll drink it here but like I I
want to I want to make my own coffee I
like when I got that grinding Brew uh
thing at home grinds of beans you use
that no I got to get that got to get
that AR's got that [__] Beaker thing
you know where you swirling it's called
a nose is it a
nose Woo you're hot today baby yeah AR's
got that Honker or whatever that thing
is that you know the beaker that swirls
around then he pours it out it's really
good oh is it not a French press is it
no no give this a goo it's like high-end
coffee pretentious [__] but man is the
coffee strong is tell I'm Miss sorry I
haven't seen him for [__] ever yeah
do you only do you see him outside of
the Rogan stuff or no well he's in the
tunnels so I don't know what he's up to
uh no I he's around he's doing Adrien I
paluchi specials so he text me the other
day and we had a phone call but he's
around he's he text me the other day but
I just don't I don't see him that much
is what I'm saying that's the one that
that that one with that weird um oh my
God yeah it's it's like mad scientist
[__] that plus his beard it's it's Rick
and Morty over
there how many stars does it have it's
got one review oh one review that's yeah
sori heed this a Kobe
joke but yeah I love the what was the
influence behind the pat old school
Patrick Ying uh wallpaper you changed up
it used to be dog day right I think uh
Chad Daniels was talking about yeah Pat
I can't remember why but uh I just love
the thing at the bottom says starting
October 26th the New York skyline will
never be the same I mean that's gold
it's great off by a month or so well
played well played yeah but it is a
beautiful little seems Pro New York but
you're mocking the history of New York
yeah and the know the victims
wow just Kidd no I love that picture
though that's old school man mhm that's
he he was the [__] King he was my I
almost wore uan shirt today really I had
I yeah I was looking I was like this and
this but I went long sleeve just cuz the
weather but oh yeah yeah Yu was my guy
he was the man I mean it feels like uh
NFL is heating up more than n playoffs
bab well time year yeah I mean something
about playoffs I mean you're a [__]
Buffalo guy Matt
in the
playoffs probably winning in this in the
snow man like oh yeah I think of that
iconic Brady Patriots Raiders game where
he's like freaking out they beat the I
mean it's just it's in the snow it's so
kind yeah pull up pictures of that one
it's just [__]
badass Raiders yeah I've been to a few
football games one was the bills I'll
never go back there's no [__] roof on
that Stadium it's the coldest city in
America I I think I got hypothermia holy
hell get on in here get on in here our
guest wow we started so pop on over baby
I mean look at that [__] though that's
wild Brad you're you're a football fan
right yeah yeah yeah we're talking about
the bills we got to pull Brad up get
Brad at the Broncos game this is killer
Yes yes good to see you dude and we got
your favorite drink coming up I'm going
to make us some drinks we had some
coffee just just to be uh good to see
you man thanks for coming in look at you
you're early yeah I'm early I I walked
in through the through the foot of snow
which is really a drag for me well we we
tried to get a doggy door installed for
you but uh oh my God uh I am definitely
a West Coast guy in New York cuz I don't
I I don't have the right shoes I got my
Sketcher slip-ons which are delightful
on the west coast but then East Coast
I'm stepping in puddles I got freaking
my ankles are Frost but you don't look
at the you don't look at the weather
before you come to I just know cold I I
don't but like West Coast cold is like
ah it's like 40 like like it's not wind
and wet and all are you from are you
from Denver no uh I'm from yeah I'm from
Orange County California but I'm a
lifelong Broncos fan what about the the
North Pole elves what are they doing oh
my God they they they they got something
else I guess so yeah they they oh yeah
they're trained I don't know hey got he
dead jokes kids don't like them yeah
kids don't like
them that's great yeah uh this is when
the de
Broncos they really are hard for
celebrity fans they they they don't have
a lot so they got do they hook you up
yeah they they got me so they gave me
tickets field passes it's like me and
Angela from the
officebe that's it the Aurora shooter
yeah may may yeah maybe yeah maybe them
that's about it in terms of celebrity
fans so uh my my my advice to Young up
and cominging influencers Comics
whatever is to pick a team that nobody
likes ah the Saints yeah so you can be a
Saints fan cuz who else is a Saints fan
it's me and
uh yeah I I don't know it's Jared from
Subway I don't know it's me and Cosby
yeah yeah and uh yeah so that that's it
pick don't go like New York Giants New
York Jets
un see you're so far down the list and
and that's just I'm also just [__]
watching that team this year Jesus
Christ if I ever see this again I'm
going to kill myself this [__] was just
pull up this guy the dad and the agent
was too [__] much it's kind of funny
though when you're losing and you at
least get funny [__] you know yeah right
yeah cuz then like you're like okay my
team sucks but I get a scene from The
Sopranos in the STS where they're just
doing that thing and wa I haven't seen
this this you haven't seen this guy oh
this guy Tommy DeVito he was like a
third string quarter back they call him
Tommy cutlets his fan I mean that's his
agent that's his agent oh that's his
agent but his agent just got inducted
into the national italian-americans Hall
of Fame so like first of all how hit up
were they were they like oh Tommy
DeVito's agent we've known who he is for
three days wow yeah get him into the
Hall of Fame between him and Vincent
Pastor do you have a vow that ends your
name you're in wow who's next Mike
biglia
Jesus holy [__] he is Italian oh yeah
you're Italian I know I'm I'm sicil but
but Bley had that great joke back in the
day like I wouldn't say I'm it I'm like
Olive Garden Italian which is such a
perfect line but by the way you know
who's Italian who's that Nate barazi
that's true bargi but he doesn't play it
up no he doesn't if he all you have to
do is play it up funny like they they
get mad about stereotypes but then the
first guy they [__] induct they're
like don't you stereotype us this guy's
like oh yeah oh he's [__] my own they
St typers we're not Mobsters hold on I'm
getting a call later like it's just come
on it's like yeah tongs Nate barazi
plays up the Tennessee thing way way
more than the Italian thing right that's
so true yeah now I got to ask cuz uh you
go to the Denver game they [__] go
nuts they love it they love you it must
be nice you just make people happy right
when you show up pull up the clip of him
dancing from my Instagram they put it on
my uh they they they put it on the big
screen me dancing but yeah no it's great
it's nice that it's nice to be someone
that when I show up people are like ah
this guy's here totally I mean it's not
the opposite I mean you have your
hardships in other ways obviously but uh
as you never have to buy a first class
ticket that's got to be nice right never
although wow although I will say this
man I will say this with the first class
tickets uh on my flight out here in New
York there it is right there in the
middle
yeah what do you go overhead Ben look at
him go yeah and they even put Brad
Williams comedian on the big screen so
like you know all right this isn't just
a random dancing dwarf this isn't
a they're going nuts right yeah the
place is going nuts here here's the
thing that is amazing the guy sitting
next to me on my left he's an older guy
he's got mutton chops oh yeah and uh
he's lipsyncing to who let the
dog and I think that might be the most
Progressive thing I've ever seen that
guy shout out to that guy his name is
Rob he's he's actually a master
distiller of whiskey whoa Robbie hit us
up yeah uh uh he he distills Metallica's
whiskey what blackened yes and uh yeah
it's a great whiskey that's and he's a
friend of mine I took him to the game
Hey sir your Rush yeah your favorite
drink is a gold rush we heard
so and he looks like a
prospector cheers when he wants some oh
I've never had a gold rush oh it's
delightful that's good you made it oh
you made it well really job yeah it's a
little honey syrup a little lemon juice
and a little uh a little Bodega whiskey
you got that right huh it's kind of like
in the
same very good give him a sponsorship
it's like the same neighborhood of a
whiskey sour kind of yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah sometimes you can throw a little
ginger in there if you're if you're
feeling fancy good blacken I thought
that was Rachel doa's whiskey all right
I'll see you guys next week okay no but
I was saying with the whole uh uh every
seats first class uh on the flight over
here this is this is a pet peeve of mine
it's like all right if I get it that the
seats can go back the coach seats can go
back they have that capability if you're
sleeping okay but the lady behind me or
the the lady in front of me just slammed
the seat back hard as she could my water
bottle went flying cuz it was on the
trade table right and then she didn't
like sleep she just like sat straight up
not even putting her back against it and
I'm like no you you [__] sleep yeah
you got to lean on that lady I that's a
peeve when they're like keep hitting it
and I'm like it's all the way back it's
back [__] and that's and that's me with
no legs my tall friends they they sit
back yeah you you you sit back they slam
the seat into you and then they look
back like well excuse me and it's like
that's that's your [__] legs yes you
can't stop that oh sorry my legs were in
the way well the this is the debate as
old as time do you recline or do you not
recline what which one is right which
one is wrong I say you recline if you're
sleeping okay like if you're using it
right like if you're actually using it
but but even so just a courteous look
back I agree of like what's up are you
okay and a slow descent slow don't slam
it
down than that a slow descent uh you
ever see the people where they throw the
this people with long hair where they
throw the
I now I have to now I have to part your
hair to watch succession [__] like a
curtain you do that I'm pulling your
hair like I I think that's only fair
right and that that that that's how you
tell the flight attendant you need
service is You Yank on the hair the
person screams and then the flight
attendant comes back I think that I I I
think that works out well are you
alcohol on a flight coffee on a flight
what are you drink oh I'm uh alcohol if
it's an afternoon flight uh but I'm a
tea drinker I don't drink coffee oh so I
I have a tea you know and I ask for a
little cream and they give me a little
separate cup for the bag and I feel very
fancy uh okay now I'm going to sound
like an [__] uh I like I bring my own
tea on the flights oh boy here we go cuz
I don't like their tea it's very basic
it's very like an English breakfast a
cam me I want to know what the good tea
is I mean I in the winter occasionally
I'll do some tea yeah I I I don't have
Brands I just kind of look at it and
it's got a fancy label I go yeah that
one okay well like what flavors are we
talking oh if if if you got like a
ginger green tea I'm all I'm all over
that I'm all over that or like uh ear
Earl Earl Gray but I got syrups at my
house so I'll make like an earl gray
with lavender syrup ah it's delightful
wow you're like a mixologist with tea I
am it's pretty great and then I got I
got uh British friends and I tell them
about the teas I'm make and they're like
you're you're [__] but the had but had I
could tell you had British Friends by
the way yeah right that's okay I look
like a long jockey I do they have when
they have tea in the Green Room
sometimes I'll do especially when you're
doing like a lot of shows like they had
throat cat I was like that's a good
[__] flavor on a tea it's a good idea
that's a good tea yeah yeah that's what
I called my ex in college throat coat
but remember when it went viral that it
was that Nancy Reagan was called throat
goat yes what a weird [__] rumor that
she gave the best low jobs there's no
way they use the word goat back in
the'80s no no it's recent but they now
they say throat they weren't saying
throat
goat the throat goat the only people
using that back in the day were like
pervy Farmers I think so like she gave
such a good [__] that Reagan lost his
memories she sucked the memories out
he's got nothing left in there it must
have been other people cuz I doubt
Ronald was being like you know who sucks
a good dick my wife yeah there had to be
someone else like cuz remember there was
that woman uh who wrote the book like 10
years ago s uh supahead like she she she
like had sex with all the Amber Rose uh
no not not her I don't remember her name
but she wrote a book about all the dudes
she'd slept with it was like it was like
all the rappers all the athletes yeah
Karen stefins oh wow um all the rappers
all all the athletes and Bill Maher hey
who's apparently huge down town yeah
well endowed really oh yeah real talk
really you're going to suck me off oh
here's the thing okay she's going to go
down on me she's going to cup the balls
it's going to feel good but am I going
to come no he's [__] her she's like
oh God he's like oh yeah God that's an
idea by by the way my impression of Bill
Mah is just me doing an impression of
Kyle D yeah me too too he does the best
one so shout out to him did you see the
clip of of Rogan trying to show Bill Mar
impression threatened to walk out which
I'm like dude just it's it's an
impression he he he's sitting there like
I don't sound like that at all where you
think that's me that's what you're going
to that's what you think I sound like
absolutely not yeah so that's him and
Superhead by the way what a nickname
Superhead what what a ni you better
bring the heat though it's kind of like
cuz Pete Davidson's got that joke about
how how Ariana Grande told everyone he
had a huge dick and now he's like now
he's cursed to be like whenever he shows
it to a woman Cur no no no hear me out s
like a blessing look he's it's a first
world problem but he says now whenever
he shows it to someone they're always
going to be a little disappointed
because of the reputation of being huge
so it's almost like you better bring the
heat with every be you can't have off
day that that's like the exact opposite
of me cuz because I'm a dwarf they're
just like holy [__] something over 3 in
WoW give that guy a participation
trophies 3 in
bad but you know what it's like it's
like when a a young comic is like this
next guy is one of the greats he's
amazing you got and you're like no no
I'm working on new [__] yeah new [__]
yeah I'm going to be bad lower the bar
what does Chris Rock always say when he
shows up at the seller lower your
expectations every time it it it's a
totally good move though it works yeah
just like yeah I know you're excited but
cool it a little bit yeah yeah this is a
good drink by the way very nice I think
we've had it once before I think beard
Jew made it for us once but I it's
really good I I I dig it man that's one
thing I would have loved to have told
myself in my younger drinking days is
like cuz I used to drink like a frat boy
you know like it's just shots it's
whiskey Cokes it's that all that I I
would have been like hey man get like
two nice cocktails and that's your night
like two nice two nice cocktails that
you sip you enjoy get the buzz yeah get
the buzz but every that's the problem
when you're young everyone's a [__]
animal so it's like everyone does this
then you're the odd man out if you have
yeah cuz they're all like passing around
shots of Patron and you're like I'll
take a Manhattan it's like now you look
like an [__] and then that and
there's certain bars that you go to and
you're like okay I can order a cocktail
at this bar and there's certain bars
that you go to which is a lot of the
bars we probably all went to in our 20s
where you're like I'm not ordering
anything beyond whiskey Coke or rum and
coke like that's what they can make
you're trying to get the most bang for
your buck when you're young and Mark and
I always talk about there's a bar in the
East Village called the Continental 10
bucks for five shots I don't know if
they still do that deal dud you walk in
and it was like seriously he died
someone died doing that it was in the
front page of the post oh my god well
you can't you got to trust the
Post they always have accurate headlines
there's one thing I know as a West
coaster the New York Post never lies it
was Greg
Geraldo 10 shots for no five shots for
10 bucks uh yeah it was bad at at at a
place called the Continental exactly
it's like a classy joint yeah oh there's
weer good luck finding head he had a
good weer was that was an incredible
have you seen the documentary on him I
heard it's good it's incredible really
cuz it's just insane that he first off
comes back com back he comes back from
all the adversity and then he somehow
[__] up again yes wait he cheated with
text and then he got what did he was he
cheated on no he cheated straight up Che
straight up cheated yes and he got
busted originally because he posted a
Twitter pick he did it was a classic I
don't know how to use Twitter thing so
he posted a picture of him in his
underwear and by the way he's in pretty
good shape oh ripped and uh he's got a
little the bill Mah thing going on he
was doing all right dude if your name if
your last name's wiener you better be
packing you got to like I don't know you
got to be hanging weights from that
thing like do do do whatever you can
yeah get the implant no he was uh he was
looking good and then on top but then
what he did the second time was kind of
like unforgivable I think he sent the
dickpic with the the with the kid in the
background which I'm like have you heard
of the crop yeah you got to crop the
picture now no woman's like oh cool he's
also a dad yeah right he's a family man
that's not not a good move yeah now and
and you guys don't have kids uh I've got
a daughter uh I've never while even
while the baby monitor is on that I that
I that I can be like I can get hard no
it's in you I cannot do it so I can't I
can't imagine your kid is literally
sleeping next to you and you're like you
know it would be a good thing to do
right
now that that's the thought you're not
like living in the moment like ah this
is great me and my kid we're having a
cuddle it's awesome it's like no Ro Rock
heart this is what I got to send out
like it it like I don't know if he got a
poner randomly he's like I can't waste
this I take a photo right now that's my
argument for whenever people are like oh
you have a baby I have a dog and I'm
like yeah but you could [__] [__] with a
dog in the bed you can't [__] with a
baby in the bed hey hey easy I can [__]
with that thing next to me in two
seconds yeah no that dog [__] I thought
she lost the
eye you better you better keep noodle
away from my dog here this is uh Sam's
publicist oh this is this is my
publicist too okay hey her uh her I I
found out yesterday that her name is a
verb uh is that if you've been low
shacked that means you've been hit up
like a lot for one for for one of her
true that is true Urban
Dictionary I I I saw like do do em
people's much about me as other people
oh I when when you have a publicist and
all she does is be like have this person
on your podcast have this person your
podcast I'm like can you get me on some
podcast yes good
point okay all right I'll see you when I
believe it I'll believe it when I see it
rather we've been drinking to be fair
Sam you're posting clips of you like
roasting morning TV and then you're like
how come you can't get me on morning TV
you know
what they don't watch those clips uh oh
easy dog fight get noodle over here
let's see all right so do I so do I have
to referee this
thing that'd be that that'd be a great
official job for little people that
would be great oh oh [__] she's only got
one eye but that one sense is danger
yeah right this is black on white here
this is a little
racial
she she's a nice dog winny Jesus winny
lived in the streets for many many years
Compton
Compton oh when he throws down wonder he
lying I feel I I feel like us watching
these dogs maybe think about fighting is
like what you guys see if you see two
dwarves having an
argument like who something magical is
about to happen like it's a fight but
you're but you're still like a yeah yeah
yeah it's so cute when they get mad if
they go at each other they'll just turn
to coins
yeah just like two sock the Hedgehogs
running each other
right but that's what's great about
being a is it little person what's the
term now uh yeah little person or dwarf
is the accurate one okay dwarf sounds
like it's more offensive it does doesn't
it
it I'm I'm not a guy they have a thing
in the Seven Dwarves where that was
offensive now yeah that whole a that
[__] story oh okay we it no I I I get
mad about it because Al so to Briefly
summarize uh they said uh Snow White the
Seven Dwarves the new the new liveaction
Disney film uh this is a great point I
heard you say this before yeah they they
were like well we can't have dwarves
that's too that that's too offensive
that that because it was like a pure
Dinklage on Mark Maron was like oh we're
still doing the Seven Dwarves F and so
then they're like okay don't worry so
they he's like dwarf Lawrence Olivia
yeah it's like yeah okay okay dink like
I call him dink do you know him no he
doesn't show up to the
meetings but like it's like yeah we all
could be a little bit more picky about
our roles if we were getting them like
but if we were working and they're and
they're being offered to little people
if if we were just the funny lead or or
the guy but we need we need like a we
need like a dwarf Hamilton OH like the
founding fathers but they're all little
that would [__] that' be great but
podiums would [__] us up that's true
every time it dwarfs at a Podium that's
the natural enemy you can't talk at a
Podium you could have you could have a
Mount Rushmore but it's just an ant pile
yeah so then they take out the little
people instead they call it Snow White
and the Seven magical beings and they
post a photo and this looks like a drum
circle at Chico State okay like this is
look at this like a bust out a hacky
sack like like it's all different types
of people colors which don't get me
wrong I'm fine having female little
people people of color little people
like get that diversity but then have it
be the damn dwarves so then that
offended people so like okay we'll bring
back the dwarves so they brought back
the dwarves in the movie they completely
re-edited but they did it using CGI so
now all the dwarfs are CGI so now no
dwarfs are getting rolls what the hell
Tak your job these humans had jobs here
yeah this is why I'm so glad I'm a comic
I'm like okay I can just be funny ex
Christ I don't have to have uh casting
director being like okay is it is it the
right uh diversity quotient like no just
be funny but what about diversity for
you guys get about get working even
that's crazy so I went to an audition
one time and uh it it was not for a
dwarf role it was just for a role and
the casting director looked at me and
goes wow that was great but just so you
know we're looking for a diversity
higher and I was like you mean this are
you just having all sorts of dwarves B
down your door What's Happening Here
minority I I I am like o we're looking
for a trans dwarf it's like okay give me
a
week I can go down to Mexico I can have
a surgery wi can happen I can identify
as yeah they're better off doing a a
multicultural Seven Dwarves with snowy
you know get a Mexican beanie then we'll
get a diabetes we'll get we'll get all
the groups by the way beanie sounds like
a great racial slur for a Mexican dwarf
that's that was the joke that's what I
saying [__] sorry I told diab was the
black little according to Little People
of America there are an estimated 65,000
only 65,000 dwarves in the United States
that's nothing that's nothing that's
less than
Jews isn't it God willing by Million by
million is there a Jew dwarf oh of
course yeah oh you want to hear
complaining oh my god well luckily I
don't hear
it that's a tiny yamaka what is that
just a rich cracker clip
it
pull up Jud dwarf we got to see pull up
JW dwarf he's just riding on a drele
whoa this sounds like this is my
impression of a JW dwarf here's my
impression for Drew dwarf is it cold
down here hey I like
it that's good hold on I'm going to
write down all of these this going to be
brand new 10 minutes so all right so
I've been trying out this new bit oh
there you go the dwarves of aitz oh yeah
holy [__] I'm trying to make this I I
want to make this as a movie so like
this is a family of a family of little
people not CGI
you they don't have to go in the oven is
long oh my God all right they oh my God
they went in an easy bake
up clip
it they don't take trains just a Radio
Flyer so this is a whole family of
little people that uh that were that
were in awit and they the uh Nazi
doctors were like experimenting on them
and like doing medical and they survived
it they they they survived but they
obviously were uh mutilated and had a
really hard life after that but I want
to make this movie so bad cuz I mean
come on it's got It's got everything the
academy loves disability Nazis like come
on yeah minorities yeah it be a good
survival story I love it we haven't
gotten this Holocaust tale yeah yeah we
can make one of them gay come on like
let's do it let's make this movie I love
it that's a great idea why is there a
dwarf with a swasa on his chest well
there had to be dwarf Nazis as well
right you're looking for dwarf Nazis my
algorithm all [__] up now even Hitler
was like we need a diversity
hire
[Laughter]
wow oh this is killing me which is what
they said his name is bitler all
it
um well sorry oh my God what are the
what like Holocaust movies we do need a
little person what I think I I I agree I
I I think it'd be great if you're taking
away Snow White and the Seven Dwarves
from us give us something else if if
you're giving the Oompa Loompa rooll to
Hugh Grant right [__] that guy I know
we've been having a lot of Hugh Grant
trashing on this pod lately yeah yeah
well I mean you start taking rolls from
Little People you deserve it here here
yeah it it like what is he he's The
Stumbling mumbling OA looma like so so
sorry Gul
stop nice give it to another little
person come on here here God taking away
our roles so I got to yeah so I'm GNA
have to write my own dwarf holocaust
movie in order to get a [__] part I
like it I I mean this is gold it's a
shoeing it's a can't miss yeah why not
uh yeah cuz now it's award season we're
seeing all the all all the award shows
are you big movie person I like movies
but I haven't been watching a ton of
them just you know they used to be I
mean with the Marvels and the the
whatnots speaking of dude Norman wrecked
the Fargo season 5 fun right I watched
it cuz of you it's [__] killer dude
John Ham's in I love it is he your boy
uh I mean he's just he's just love we're
ham fans and ham we know you've listened
to an episode come on yeah come on come
on the Pod ham make yourself useful the
publicist wow John Ham there's another
guy who's packing oh he's got a hog on
him you see look at that H H ham has a
hog yeah ham hack yeah he's killer on it
Jennifer Jason Lee is killer on it yeah
she's great yeah yeah John Ham loves
comedy he's from St Louis he's friends
with the scaw brothers oh yeah they went
to like the same high school or
something what also uh [__] what's
Dave Foley man yeah Foley's great in it
everyone is great on it but yeah this
season's kill it's you're right Kill
Bill Vibes it's m fun it's all women you
know women forward like the women of the
heroes it's fun it's and ham kills it
Ham's like a rightwing like libertarian
type guy yeah but he's so good in the
Pierce nipples too Jesus Christ yes the
details boy what a striking handsome
hunk of a man there I I hope John Ham
was like let me think about something to
add to this character Pierce nipples
like I hope that was his idea are you
watching it uh I haven't watched it yet
but I I know everyone's been talking
about it's [__] good yeah well like
all those seasons of Fargo wasn't like
Chris Rock and one I missed that I got
to watch that one that was fun yeah
Fargo kills it and it's produced by the
Cohen Brothers so I think they they keep
an eye on it that guy Noah Holly too is
just [__] great yes he writes all of
it so yeah I I got some peeves I don't
know if you guys I I've been locking and
loaded I had a a wacky week with this
peeve Galore peeves too so buckle up
folks love a good peeve all right hold
on here we go okay first
peeve yeah I'm not crazy about the uh
you're at a restaurant you're enjoying
your meal with your buddy you're having
a good combo the manager of the
restaurant some dweeb and a tie and
glasses comes over and goes hi I just
wanted to check in see if you guys are
enjoying everything and I'm like well
that's what the waiter's for yeah we
don't need you cuz now I have to just
blow you a little I have to go oh we
love it here oh you don't say yeah he
gives you the whole and if there's
anything that that we that we can do to
make your
like that the waiter can't do exactly he
might be a fan ear well he did the whole
restaurant okay so I was I was wild I
was like here it comes T minus 2 minutes
before this guy hits our table he was a
praise [__] he was just going around
going around table to table looking for
praise like what it is how's your tear
massu come on and you could see the ey
his eyes are just like don't Yelp don't
Yelp tell tell me now whatever there's a
problem with is there anything I can do
it's like what what could you there's
nothing you can do I mean
friendly wall right over there so I can
take a selfie in your restaurant like
that's what you could do live love or
whatever the yeah yeah is there anything
to do yeah there's this one waitress who
I really want to [__] her could you put
in a word no there's nothing you can do
no nothing and you you just know it's
coming it's going to ruin the the meal
you got to go oh yeah it's great thank
you PP the dessert that's that's what
you can it's a nice restaurant thing
they're not doing that at Panera no no
they're like we actually wanted to make
sure you're having a bad time here yeah
are you guys enjoying your baguette does
your lemonade need more caffeine yeah
are you still alive can we add can we
add another shot of espresso to that
thing yeah please mind the chalk outline
over there on the floor don't they serve
coffee at Panera oh yeah it's a good
it's a good road spot actually Panera oh
it's great Road spot but I'm just saying
who who goes Panera where they have
coffee and goes lemonade I I need my
lemonade does the lemonade really have
caffeine yeah it's called charged up
lemonade oh I didn't know that yeah it's
actually killed a few people I think you
can look this up uh Panera lemonade
death really I didn't know that yeah
it's like it's like killed a few people
yeah holy [__] we should drink that next
week family sued Panera Bread after
college student who drank charged
lemonade how many did he drank though I
want to see he uh she had a heart
condition it says and wasn't where to
drink had caffeine that's fair though Le
just saying it's lemonade you don't know
yeah cuz uh the amount of caffeine
exceeds exceeds a red bow so it's more
it's more than a red bll in
lemonade contains did you just say this
I was reading sorry contains more
caffeine than a Red Bull yeah yeah yeah
yeah sorry yeah that's what I just said
there's an echo in the building okay the
glasses cover his ears as well okay uh
but yeah like the in cuz lemonade is a
sit on the front porch and freaking you
know rocking chair and have have a nice
relaxing time it's not a well I got to
have a power lunch charge up a lemonade
yeah right right I don't like I mean I
like the taste of coffee I need coffee
and all the energy drinks kind of suck I
did a monster energy no rockstar which
who sponsored myour I think it was
Rockstar was it Rock have monster
actually huh one one of the energy
drinks one of the energy drinks uh
sponsored and and they
made but they were like all right take a
sip I'm like no W I'll I'll I'll have it
on the stage but I'm not I don't I smell
it it tastes like [__] to me it's it's
chemical that being said if they bring
more money to the table I will do it
again there you go yeah and why is it
everyone I see drinking that white
monster can is like the laziest person
on the planet it's it's never a guy
who's like chugging away the Midnight
Oil doing the crunching numbers with a
green visor on just a guy you know
sitting around watching phone he's like
playing online video games he's like I
got to stay up for 20 hours kill for
night yeah it's a gamer bit remember the
about how I make uh instant oatmeal but
then I just don't do anything oh yeah I
could make the regular stuff and feel
productive a great joke that's funny
yeah these are the laziest people ever
Celsius is pretty damn good though I got
to say I like Celsius that's that's the
only one I like but I still prefer
coffee but like if you're in a rush man
mhm the the the sparkling flavors are
pretty [__] good like pretty Dam more
than a coffee too it's it's that'll [__]
that's the only one though I don't like
the taste of the others they taste like
weird energy drinks work way too well on
me oh yeah I don't drink coffee and I
don't really like energy drinks I just
like I said I just drink tea so when I
have an energy drink like it I'm up how
I never Comics who don't drink coffee I
don't understand because of our [__]
up hours like Norman used to not drink
coffee and I would be like how the hell
you do it's back when we were doing like
morning radio all the time and the
hangovers coffee will kill a hangover
which is nice too it help yeah help yeah
my whole thing is you got to for me to
like it I have to put so much sugar and
cream into it it's now like a milkshake
that's coffee flavored well the Rock
the monster is tough for you cuz you're
the size of the can you know you're 16
is I like like I hold a rockstar can
they're like what is that dwarf have a
barrel barrel of rock star right right I
I think they're all bad news and uh yeah
get a cup of coffee also like the coffee
is warm and it's inviting like you go to
a diner how you doing hun they pour you
a mug of coffee you got the mug going
nothing like a hun from a waitress oh
love a hun not and not not a hot
waitress I I I I need an older give
weathered 55-year-old she's been there
for 30 years yeah beaten maybe a few
times by the husband not on first
husband definitely on second or third a
little bit of an attitude to bit of an
attitude although you ever get the Greek
guy who's like I make it the way you
like you're like that feels that's like
a war my friend my friend I make
whatever you want uhoh yeah oh man
there's a I go to an egg sandwich place
in my
neighborhood I go to an egg sandwich
place and the guy always goes the usual
and I'm like that's a good feeling that
is huge not having to say it you just
know oh that if we ever get a sandwich
named after us I'll I'll die happy well
that Larry David episode that Cur where
he was mad he got the white fish Sable
sandwich I'm like I like those but he
wanted turkey turkey is like number one
yeah you can't go wrong with the other
white meat are you leveled up to the
point where your Deli guy knows your
name no no he doesn't know my name no
not there yet not dude see that see
that's the thing if I go to a place
twice they know me
no no no one ever goes who are you good
point is that we met no no the other one
the other one yeah like yeah I go to
place TW like I've been to I've been to
places uh grabbing a bite to eat on on
the road and then and then I'll go back
like a year later and then I'll go to
the same spot when I'm on the when I'm
in that town again and I've literally
had the guys go you never come around
anymore what the heck good to see you
again I'm like I don't live here wow
that's great that is my favorite part of
the road though is just knowing like
which Diner to just hit I mean just
having that familiarity you Dro me in
almost any City in this country I'll
find a decent Diner there's a place I've
eaten there's a there there's a good bar
something like that exact people were
like oh you going there I'm like
whatever City in this country I will
find a cool spot and I mean I was like
inspired by old bardane episodes where
you just like find the best in any place
and uh doesn't have to be the the the
the fanciest the toyy [__] you can find
a good like a good box c car
Diner can't beat it get a tuna melt a
[__] omelette something good yeah
lady with got a pencil in her hair love
that that's nice refill are are you guys
Waffle House guys I grew up on Waffle
House look I'll go but it's not like my
number one choice but like yeah I cheesy
eggs I'll [__] I'll [__] Waffle House me
it's dinner in a show n that's true
certain shows you don't want to see
though that's that 3:00 4 a.m. it could
get dicey there's a clip I mean there's
so many Waffle House fights Clips but
there there there's one where a chair
gets thrown at a waitress and she
catches I've seen that yes that one's
ridiculous well yeah she's like [__]
John Wick the crazy thing is some of
these people they're just it's it's
second nature you work a night shift of
this at this place oh yeah so my buddy
applied to be a tow truck driver and he
sat down the first thing the guy said is
can you fight and I think that's the
same as waffle yeah can your buddy fight
he could fight J it right there there it
is a white lady boom one wow that was
like some John Cena [__] yeah holy sh so
good yeah I I I I think yeah cuz there
was that thing a couple years ago where
there was there was one of the school
shootings they're like arm the teachers
I think we should arm The Waffle House
waitresses that that's who needs that's
who needs a
firearm WAFF house waitress that's so
true yeah it's WWE in there every night
yeah and this might this this actually
goes into one of my peeves is you kind
of see it in that clip now when stuff is
happening people aren't rushing to break
it up people aren't rushing to help
everyone turn everyone just takes out
the phone could you believe this [__]
phone now with like the blizzards and
when it's like natural disasters people
are walking outside like look at that
person drowning right in front of my
house like I don't know save the dude
like jump in there you got to get your
likes dude come on I know it's I
remember I was I was at a comedy club
once stand up New York back in the day
and a comic [__] snapped on stage
yeah and more
about he's going at it he's going at it
with an audience member it's a lightly
attended show yeah and they keep going
back and forth and he just puts the mic
down and does this no and I was like oh
[__] and then I you know I say to the
host I'm like man we should do something
and he goes yeah takes his phone out
videotapes that was the best thing it
could have done for that comic moment
right there I don't know fil that yeah
cuz I've had times where like the comic
was bigger than the it was not going to
be a fair fight oh it was an old dude he
started he got no fight oh wow I've had
times where I've been on stage and then
like some Heckler will yell something
out and literally right when they do the
entire audience just holds up their
phones I'm like God like stop it like
now I I I had a comeback that I was very
confident with and now I'm looking
around like ooh do I want to say this
out of context yeah good point yeah it I
I don't like it and out of context [__]
makes you look bad you know but if you
just throw if it's a deserving [__] it's
a good line wait what's what are you
pulling up oh [__] this is a front kick
a front kick I the m so this is a woman
offended or who's the comic here I don't
know it's a small town oh there he is
ohe this triggers me remember open mics
this is my first year
oh that was warranted that was War this
is when they got to play the Hulk Hogan
music I am a real
americ pull up the DC youngfly where you
he knocked the guy out on stage yeah I
mean these are some some uh what's
what's the hard pipe nword as a what a
Ving Rams line yes bringing some dudes
with pliers yeah yeah I'm going to get
me evil on your ass DC Young
Fly oh you yeah you got to right you got
to fast forward so he's talking [__] you
missed it you missed it you know Tommy
teas I've been oh I have a I have a
story like this from from Tommy te what
is this a club yeah it's in Pleasanton
California wow Pleasanton yeah that's
East Bay so not San Francisco that's
after the fight right this must be after
it says after say knocked the dude out
yeah you got to find the the actual list
had a story about doollo doing that to
some that's right yeah yeah well depalo
played football in college he's still
kind of ripped yeah he's a dude he looks
he looks good so I was at at Tommy te
the club where this happened MH and uh I
uh I did a joke that I used to do that
was
me Heckler videos and everyone's like
Sam moral that one went viral that one
oh yeah yeah some woman went at me and I
was like o Omaha funny Boone baby Omaha
I'll be back there in a couple week in a
week I think great Club I love that club
yeah Colleen what's up out to and by the
way I I did have a great time in Philly
didn't mean to sound like I was uh
saying bad stuff about the club they
were great we got to find the actual
fight maybe they scrubbed it for legal
re but it was it was everywhere for a
while but sorry with Tommy teas yeah
when I was at Tommy teas there uh I I
did a joke about how everyone thinks I'm
wean but then Wan's real name is Jason
aunia so it's like he's I go he's
Mexican I'm I'm I'm not Mexican I go oh
man Mexican dwarf something about like
uh how high does the border wall have to
be some old joke like that and uh and
then someone just yelled out [__] you
I'm not Mexican and I was like wait what
like I was talking about another guy
yeah and he was so drunk he started
yelling and the bouncers came up picked
him up and then used his head as a
battering ram to open the door and
knocked out the
window I've heard of homophobic but head
Mexican phobic that is like a weird one
good point yeah but yeah that that was a
solid one there there at Tommy T I am
not Mexican I experimented in
college that's so good I had a Jimmy
changa
once that's a good point it was a
different
time right but yeah my my thing is after
the Will Smith Dave Chappelle thing if
someone's walking up on stage you don't
know what their intentions are I know I
know there was that there there there
was that woman from The Voice uh she did
a concert and then she's doing a meet
and greet afterward and a guy just came
up and shot her in the head and killed
her what who to who there was a there
was a contestant on The Voice and she
was doing a concert uh good-look woman
yeah Christina Grimmie yeah and then uh
uh a a fan one of those like stalker
creepy guys like thinks they're married
or something like he just walks up all
it takes is one man yeah straight up
that shit's terrifying that is
terrifying I didn't even hear about this
yeah so like if someone's walking up on
stage you don't have time to like
discuss like hey what are your
intentions right now oh no it's so funny
that that you feel more so uh paranoid
ever since it's Will Smith that did that
to you it's like like I don't trust this
dude in this Toledo strip mall because
of the Fresh Prince that's true that's a
good point but it's true I definitely
put my and then the Chappelle thing
happened not long after that and but you
know I remember at the Sellar one night
a guy threw a [__] beer bottle at
Dave AEL really and AEL
[__] the sweetheart he is yeah guy
was shitfaced got arrested David tell
gave his friend bailout
money jeez [__] best dude the world
doesn't deserve David here here he's so
good right the best dude and the nicest
dude yeah and still one of my favorite
comebacks for a Heckler uh I was
watching him at the Irvine Improv and he
did some joke and some lady yelled [__]
you Dave and then he responded by going
all I heard was Co come gurgle gurgle
and the sound and the sound of a father
crying
wow so good so good he's the king he's
the best I've told this story before but
I saw there was a guy a black guy in the
front row with dreadlocks like a super
hipster guy and he goes what are you
doing here and the guy goes I'm a huge
fan of yours he goes you're a fan of
mine geez most of my fans look like they
can pull a dead dog out of a fountain
without flinching but can't tell their
daughter I love you I was like where did
he pull that from oh my god I've never
heard that one that's phenomenal I think
it was on the on the Fly and never again
he uh I remember one time at the seller
three dudes in glasses cuz you have to
walk through the room to go to the
bathroom three dudes with glasses all
come into the bathroom and Dave goes
what is that a nerd
portal
crushes yeah we got to get him on here
for a special he and we're going to have
to we're gonna have to pull him Kicking
and Screaming because he hates doing
pods but you know his special I think is
going to be on Netflix so I think it is
yeah got to get low shacked yeah
get on
here yeah [__] tell new special very
that's like the best thing to happen in
comedy for a while mhm there's very few
that I Circle that I'm like I got to
watch yeah yeah yeah and Dave is just
the best obviously after my special
dropped on veps and you watch that is
yours on where's your special right now
exactly uh VSS with Julia Louis drist
that's where you can find it yes yes
doing that yeah veps they they start off
as like a concert thing so you could
watch concerts they got shows by like
Alicia Keys and Imagine Dragons up there
and now they're doing comedy specials
like it's like me David Cross Reggie
Watts yeah starfish that's the new
special look at that look at that slick
back hair you look nice great jacket I
love it yeah mixed colors baby yeah
orange and blue Broncos fan so that's
why they're going to put this on Netflix
with Hugh
Grant of
he was going to start doing my jokes you
know it's it's very it's very hard to be
a little person very hard very hard to
be a dwarf yeah uh well the problem with
dwarf comedy it's a low bar all right
but no this is great and you know at one
point Netflix was a veps that was like
hell what's this let's try it out and
you never know so this is cool yeah I
love it man I mean and it looks well
shot look at that it looks [__] great
cats uh cat did cats direct this uh
Jason cats Jason cats the guys from 800B
gorilla whatever yeah oh Anthony yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah hey hey
draftking sports book folks it's an
official sports betting partner of the
NFL playoffs it's bringing you an offer
that's going to make the playoffs
seriously awesome new customers get or
can bet five bucks on any game and get
200 instantly in bonus bets everything's
more fun when you got some skin in the
game and DraftKings makes it easy to get
involved download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app now and use code
wmbd new customers can bet just five
bucks to get 200 instantly in bonus bets
only on draftking Sportsbook with code
wmbd the crown is yours got a gambling
problem call 1800 Gambler or visit ww.
1800 gambler. net in New York call 8778
Hope and Y or text hope Andy 467 369 do
we do all the states in Connecticut help
is available for problem gambling call
888 7897 777 or visit ccpg dog please
pay responsibly on behalf of are we
going to get to South Dakota here I have
a booill casino in Resort in Kansas 21
plus age varies by jurisdiction void in
Ontario bonus bets expire 168 hours
after issuance C dk.com for eligibility
and deposit restrictions terms and
responsible gaming
[Music]
resources is finally quitting that nasty
hand-to mouth habit on your to-do list
this year if you're really struggling to
quit bad habits it's time to check out
fume fume is an Innovative award-winning
flavored air device that's totally going
to turn your habit on its head keep
everything you've been doing taking a
step outside fidgeting with your hands
getting a little break from the world
but the bad part of the Habit is
completely gone that's because instead
of vapor fume uses flavored Air instead
of electronics fume is totally natural
instead of harmful chemic chemicals fume
uses delicious flavors uh Mark smokes
this [__] like crazy he's not here right
now to tell you about it he's pissing
but uh I don't smoke but Mark had to
kick this stuff many times Mark used to
do heroin he's really turned his life
around stick with the original or kick
things up a not with a brand new Solano
fume it's made with a premium Walnut
barrel and an onx coated mouthpiece with
a slightly softer finish right now is
the best time to start the Good Hat it
with fume all orders for a month of
January have a buy one get one cores so
you can stock up for the New Year's
resolution plus our listeners get an
extra 10% off when you use our code head
to
fum.fi wow great our friends Rachel feon
and Keith Robinson just shed specials
there for for Netflix great venue it's
uh you know it's like it's larger than a
club smaller than a theater so it's got
the noise but still intimate and uh yeah
it was a lot it was a lot of fun hope
everyone enjoys enjoys the go and watch
that right now so it's at vs.com yeah
vs.com you do vs.com Brad Williams or
vs.com and just SE and just search for
it after you watch the uh Alter Ego
concert with some 41 in yellow card then
then you could go watch my comedy I was
at that concert it was [__] great
hell yeah I kind of like those those
Tunes man those like very 90s like yeah
uh uh Adam Divine had a great joke about
those kind of punk bands where it's like
every song started off with uh a season
and a location so every song is like
summer the
city that's killer it was fall my
grandmother's house like it's all that
kind of [__] what's funny cuz those I
used like Blink 182 and all that [__] it
is it's like sad boyfriend hu uh songs
but they put it with like a good
Baseline it's all just whiny dudes like
she don't she broke my heart and then I
fart you know or whatever but I feel
like they're having a Resurgence splink
182 yeah oh really well well cuz they're
back on tour some 41 just announced it's
their last tour and then they're going
to break up to which everyone was like
they were still together yeah also I
think it's some 58 at this point like
how old are we I I I saw him a few days
ago they [__] killed it all right
were great he was banging a LaVine for a
while that front man yeah Derek uh
something he's Canadian so uh yeah she
likes to keep it in the in the Canadian
family cuz she was also with the lead
singer Nickelback wow really a LaVine
was with the lead singer yeah there he
is that's a tough look that's a some 41
guy or yeah that's a some 41 guy so he
yeah he looks a lot better now he had a
he had he had a bit of an addiction
problem for a rock star I know who knew
as you should that's appropriate but
yeah now he's thin he's got more energy
than anything like he was running around
on stage I heard charge lemonade is the
[Laughter]
secret but yeah they [__] killed it
man and the whole the whole crowd's in
their mid to in their mid-30s just
dancing around and all the people
younger than that are like when when's
the 1975 coming on I don't I don't know
about them I I don't know I I'm not sure
but the but the girls were going crazy
when they when they came on STS yeah
they're they're pretty huge but uh what
was that F was like Nostalgia Fest it
was in Vegas it was huge we might be or
we're no longer young we might be young
something that broke records for a
tickets yeah it was like some 41 My
Chemical Romance there it is when we
were young When We Were Young kind of a
sad notion but it it [__] worked
there there there are certain genres of
music that uh like Green Day up top
Green Day hell yeah that's a big G who
beat up a dwarf come on I know well
there's no dwarf hate who was beating
you up who was
uh you hear that how do you feel now man
how bad were you getting beat up not
that bad because people like people like
beat me up one time and then got
suspended and uh I was friends with a
lot of the older kids and then they they
retaliated yeah so hell yeah I was all
right well the problem with beating up a
bullying a dwarf is they give you a
swirly you might go in you know Down the
What to Brad He's the sewage processing
plant right
now right there that's not that's
there's no way that's
him San Diego are you from I'm not from
San Diego but I'm from Southern
California is that photo what's he do
now oh this is good
experienced that's
him [__] logistic specialist the first
time
found
we see you in in San Diego hey we played
the baloa Mark it's going down baby I'm
playing the Balboa this uh this week
holy [__] two tickets and by that I mean
10 fingers let's [__] go [__]
let's
go holy [__] I apologize dude you invite
him as a friend and then you [__]
Corner his
assw I'll I'll do the uh what everyone
said that uh uh uh Collins did like have
the one Spotlight come down on him and
they start doing jokes about I'll do
that move holy [__] holy [__] he's in
the crowd you'd think there'd be more in
Southern California yeah true apparently
not there's one if he's in the crowd be
like oh what was that uh get him out of
here tase him just make up that he
heckled he said the N word he did I
heard him click back on
it h i feel like I need to apologize for
your fans that are now going to look him
up and message him but hey he he he's an
experienced inside outside sales
representative and Logistics specialist
I don't know what that is so uh I don't
know either oh at the University yeah so
if you need that glad a guy that beat
the [__] out of you when you're in
fourth grade is a teacher now that's
great yeah right
Jesus don't get too mad at him he was a
kid at time we were kids I'm I'm kidding
obviously don't don't don't like bomb
him with hate mail
with feel like it and do it you know
unless you're a dwar dwarf civil rights
activist go go right ahead so how how
bad did they get him back what's that
how bad did they get H uh they not not
like you know not like they beat him up
beat him like it was it just like they
roughed him up a little bit he was fine
he came to school the next day okay like
this th this wasn't like Tommy DeVito
calling his boys having and and having a
little leg clubbing like that like that
did not happen that's so crazy you found
the guy well done the one time you
[__] nail it Sal Jesus Christ he
can't find one of my recent
tweets but he's able to track down
people what do you like you're now going
to give him
the every year the best and fastest
thing he found which which will never be
the
G-Spot jokes wo doy all right oh man you
got any bullies let's pull them up
bullies nah I don't want I don't want
any ex we should go
after anybody [__] the football player
after you yeah let's do it why not
you're playing the bboa that's a big
deal it is that's a great room it is
it's a great room thankfully it uh it's
sold out and uh so I'm I'm doing okay
and it's nice you so you guys have your
whiskey uh uh in in San Diego I have a
beer really I'm co-owner of a brewery
down there it's called Thorn Street
Brewery hell yeah yeah get the uh get
the get get the bario logger it's Brew
it's brewed with 100% pure Agave it's
delightful wow I love I love San Diego
man what a town great City I always have
a great time there great people yeah
there you go uh and and the crowds are
[__] good oh the crowds are killing
and the whole Gaslight District that's
where all the bars and stuff are I think
that's where my ex-girlfriend lived The
Gaslight
District that's why you like it good
memories there yeah yeah it it it's a
great town to go to it really is and you
guys so you guys played the bble
together O A melada yeah yeah I love a
melada you love a melada why the [__]
not yeah you don't like a Mitchel I like
a Mitchel I like a bloody mary Mo but
I'll do a mitch I don't like I don't
like tomato juice so I'm not a fan but
if you enjoy ours go for it how do you
not have Pony sizes I mean I feel like
you missed the boat on that we got kegs
all right all right but um La Hoya's
killer too I mean all of San Diego the
whole place is great just a fun fun town
you you got any peeves I got some peeves
I got one you ever you ever do this I I
I screwed I I forgot something I said to
someone I was like ah I'm an idiot and
then and she goes no you're not and I
was like I was like yeah I was kidding
no I wasn't like questioning my being
but then it makes you wonder now does
she think I am yeah exactly yeah cuz she
said it with the exact same tone that
when a very large person goes I feel fat
in this you're like no yes yes you're
not fat you're you're doing right look
at you look at you like they said it
with the exact same t look at you
they're like I am I am that's the
problem then the worst is when you cut
you try to be nice and you're like
you're plump you're not fat you're plump
and they're like oh no this is worse
yeah plump yeah you just start going
through uh Gabriel Gus's levels you're
you're husky Porky fluffy like all
that and they're just like oh I feel hor
I feel worse now yes yes uh that's a
good one someon there yeah it's like
when you do a joke and your act and they
go a like no no I'm joking I'm joking
yeah I hate the a that's that's a rough
one not a fan of it that and it's like
hey we're up here we're doing okay that
and sometimes you get an awe when you
when you're playing a theater you're
like look around yes I'm doing okay it's
going to be fine relax the awe is weird
because I I remember thinking about it
they do they usually do it cuz they care
about you sometimes it's a bit where
you're just like oh that was too sad I
guess it wasn't funny enough but it's
also us and all we like no but it was
self-deprecating I'm clearly okay with
it I wrote it I wrote it EXA made it
happen all right all right I got a PE
you got one hit me baby uh this is
probably just for me but uh uh I hate it
when people call me big guy I hate that
[__] interesting hey what's up big man
like I I hate that like like they're
trying to fool me right yeah cuz it
feels sarcastic yeah you know although
stavos always calls me big dog and then
we were on a group thread with another
friend of and he called him big dog and
I was like that's my
[__] the hell do you do there ouch
were you just thinking like oh that's
just what he calls everyone where he
doesn't know their name no I'm big dog I
was supposed to be big dog staros oh
that stings it hurts it's like when your
wife catch you calling someone baby you
know I'm not going to lie uh Adam
Ferrara calls me pal and then I found
out he calls everybody pal I I I kind of
felt the same way of like a I thought I
was Bobby Collins used to do cuz he
didn't know anyone's name at the seller
Bobby Bobby Collins by the way could
[__] hoop this is old school com is
that right I swear to Gods Bobby pull
Bobby Collins we called him Bobby
buckets he he he was a dirty player and
he would never miss maner Bobby Buck guy
Bobby Collins classic he doesn't miss a
jump shot he would pull on your short so
you couldn't get he was so [__] dirty
was great but he was hilarious and at
the seller he would always go hey you
handsome cuz he just didn't know
anyone's name yeah and he go the way hey
you're gorgeous yeah and that and
someone calls you handsome you're not
you're not going to be like [__]
right good point man is that a Michael
Jackson jacket Cesar Palace wow well he
is dripping with confidence he was the
search guy in the80s is that right he he
bought a home with search money in the
smile holy [__] that's what they say
when you call them up I called them up
they
went now this is this this bit's aging
well
dude I I won't say the comics
name I'll tell you guys off there but
all I was at the Improv in Hollywood one
time and I saw like a 1980s comic that's
kind of like that sort of style and uh
he was doing a bit where he was doing
the accent and stuff like that and you
and you just saw the audience just like
nope and you saw the look on his face
and you saw the [__] cuz he's like oh
[__] it's passed me by like it I it's
gone like I can't do
El you got to write a new bit in 30
years I mean that's 40 years whatever
but I remember like Buddy Hackett was
the first one to do the Chinese voice
bit and it was like groundbreaking at
the time but then at a certain point
yeah it becomes not cool right right
right new bit it's fine like uh we have
uh uh we have Argus Hamilton at the co
at The Comedy Store and he writes new
jokes every week
like the news he's got
it he's almost 80 years old and he still
goes up writes new [__] I love that he
was plowing MSY for a while he was and
wait wait play play a little this is
this the Buddy want show one wanton one
egg drop one more egg drop two egg drop
one
wanton what's that this sounds like the
record egg no we don't have a sprit pee
no we didn't have a yesterday and we
don't have a tomorrow but you listen to
some of these old records though and
even like Rickles will be it's funny
when a guy's doing Crow work on record
cuz you can't see he's like look at this
Oriental fella and you're like I can't
it must have also been so nice to be a
comic back in the 40s and 50s cuz
everything was new you're like that
Chinese guy sounds
funny oh this this is good stuff no
one's done this yet wait dogs and cats
are different hold on let me write that
down the Irish drink like just like you
can just do that [__] completely
revolutionary totally it's why like if
you listen to Old prior records it
sounds hacky now but then you realize
like oh he was the first one to do that
and then every other comic after that
was just doing a version of Prior oh
yeah definitely so all right I got one
more peeve how about this one the guy
who tells you how you're going to feel
about something before he tells you the
thing so he goes uh oh dude I got a
story you're going to find this
interesting so um so I was at the uh the
mall the other day and a guy fell asleep
or whatever and I'm like well I I don't
think that's that interesting you can't
tell me you know oh oh you're going to
love this he needs a running star cuz
he's so used to people tuning him out
that's what it is that's exactly right
what it is he the same person who does
this hey hey I got a I got something
they're trying to keep you listening
they they're used to people ignoring
them and I want to ignore but he got me
he reeled me in cuz I feel bad now CU
I'm like oh this guy's actually kind of
boring so I got to overcompensate and
really pretend to care along those same
lines uh as a comic if you meet people
after the show they start they start
talking you're like oh you're going to
love this you can use this in your the
face use this you're just like no I
guarantee you I won't and 98% of the
time you're going to tell me a street
joke that's just been told a million
times before it's not my bit no or the
guy who who slips on the sidewalk and he
goes oh man I'm giving you material and
you're like well how would that go all
right so uh I was outside the other day
and a guy
slipped oh dude I guy come up to me
after the show once he goes he goes oh
you could use this in your act I got a I
got a [__] in the car the other day
older guy and I was like what what how
am I going to write a oh so this guy I
met after show got roadhead and uh
they're like why why are you telling us
this like that that's how kind of that's
where the narcissism bleeds in cuz
they're like what what happened to me it
it's funny it's real good you're going
to love this [__] and it's it's that
thing where it's like you you just saw
me do my job for an hour hopefully well
and then at the end of me killing you
you sort like I can help him yeah oh
yeah I can help him with no with no
experience whatsoever yeah cuz the hard
the hard part of Comedy is having an
idea and then the turn the turn is the
hard part that's where the skill comes
in but they just want to give you the
slipping guy on the sidewalk or the
roadhead and then you come up with the
turn and they go you're welcome you're
like no no not you're welcome I had to
do the hard part it is uh yeah it is
weird when they do that but I think
they're a lot of these people don't have
people who are honest with them in their
life cuz you know like we have to they
have to be honest with us yeah or you
know
they're not going to fake laugh through
a ticket they paid for right right right
so we have to kill hard enough that it
you know warranted the ticket the ticket
price the two drinks whatever but a lot
of people are just like their friends
are like oh yeah that's funny they
they're your friend yeah that's why your
friends when you start are like you
should do comedy and you're like yeah I
should right A lot of people your
friends push you into it and then you
[__] eat [__] cuz these people aren't
your friends and they don't give a [__]
but I also think that's why and maybe
I'm being uh too philosophical
bullshitty here but I think that's why
comedy so popular because it can't work
if it's not good if it doesn't if it's
not good it won't work like if you tell
a joke and they don't laugh that's it
there's no softening it of you know like
hey let's be nice we got to be positive
we got to be compassionate it's just
joke work laugh or not that's it same
with sports or fighting yeah you know it
just if you if you fight the guy and you
beat him up you win very simple there's
no like well it's uh it's a little
person so let's be extra nice and we
have to be participation trophy yeah we
have to be diverse and whatever it's
just quality versus no quality oh I
would I would totally watch a dwarf
fight League oh hell yeah absolutely do
you I have a question though about that
I
participate I want my revenge I'm doing
some push-ups do you uh do you think
like dwarfs are not taken into account
for diversity not at all not no we're
not don't I mean it's kind of [__] up
right I think I know why why is well a
you got no no group against you you got
a group against you women a lot of
people hate women especially Pam and
then uh you know black have Clan you
know there's group you got everybody
loves a little person yeah there's no
like anti- dwarf League yeah I mean we
should start
one I mean the most you have is the
roller coaster business who says you got
to be this tall I guess yeah there's no
like group of people that are going
outside of dwarf Holmes burning
lowercase te's
I got it women on dating apps nothing
below six feet that is true I mean I'm
not on the dating ABS anymore I'm
married but i' i' I've seen a lot of uh
women that go like if you're if you're
under six foot tall [__] keep on walk
keep swiping you're like put anything
else on on anything anything else I know
if you pray to a god that's not
Vishnu [__] right the hell off I'm with
you I'm five 10 so I was like what the
[__] you know and then every guy's got
the hack joke like I can't put 400 lb no
no fatties or whatever but it is a
little harsh yeah so yeah so so we get
it in the dating world I I don't say
this too often but thank God I'm married
I'm done yeah how do you meet your wife
uh on a on an app called uh you can look
up this app uh it's called field I've
heard of field field is basically Tinder
but for people trying to have threesome
hell yeah
wow yeah that's how that's how it matter
wow wait is that I think it's more than
just threesome is it yeah it's like you
can it's for alternative lifestyle
whatever and are you guys still into
that or was that just how you met uh
that's how we met the whole thing is
like that's how we met
too like I matched with two women and we
were all going to go out together and
then and then one of the women didn't
show up and then I I I went on a date
with just the other woman and God ended
up marrying her cuz when you find a hot
Asian likes three ways lock it down
yeah hell yeah lock that down still
looking so yeah that's how yeah that's
how I met her and uh it's tough to do
that now with the kid like it's tough to
like now it's like there's one more
schedule that we got to figure out yeah
and so we don't really do the that kind
of thing anymore unfortunately sure sure
but hey you had a good run I had a great
run you know throw throw my jersey in
the rafters it was a lot it was a lot of
fun now do you feel like you got to
really bring the heat cuz you're you're
you're representing all the littles oh
yeah when I [__] I'm [__] on behalf
of a people yeah exctly like whenever I
was with someone new it's like whatever
I do that's what they assume like oh
that's what all of his people do so it's
like that's a lot of pressure sometimes
I would do random things like cuz I knew
it would give him a
story like just pop up and give her like
a macho man elbow
drop you know just like climb the bed
post and yell out from the top rope all
a sudden she's like Ah that's what
dwarfs do they CL they they they climb
the bed post step into a slim gym yell
out oo yeah and drop the hammer must be
hard to do all that in the tree but I
assume that's where you live but that
doesn't make sense you got to you
represent your people like I feel that
way as a Jew when I leave a tip oh I got
to bring the heat on a tip I can't be so
you're going straight 25% some to go
more it depends $6 million 6 million W
you had you had a very good year last
year never forget to tip a holocaust
joke but I was trying to tag it sorry I
forgot
appr we got to make that movie God damn
it I feel like well I think the
stereotype as a guy you ever wait tables
I was cater but never waited tables oh
okay I waited tables for 10 years okay I
think the black not tipping is a bigger
stereotype than the Jew note tipping is
it oh yeah and I had black waiter
friends who were like I don't want that
table straight up yeah so that was a
tough spot oh see yeah I was never
waiter I got offered several times to
have a plate of nachos on my
head I wish that was a
joke Mexican restaurant that was like I
got a great idea I I I I we're going to
put a plate of nachos on your head you
walk around the restaurant and then
people just take chips and take nachos
it'll be free but it'll be something
that we can be known for and I'm like
great that sounds like a lot of fun for
me like no you'll get tips I'm like I'm
good I'm I'm fantastic yeah that doesn't
sound like a fun can you can you imagine
like and it's to that your point earlier
about there's no group that's like anti-
little person like can you can you
imagine if you're like H we found a guy
in a wheelchair we're going to put a
plate of nachos on his lap we'll call it
Meals on Wheels it's going to be
fantastic like doesn't no one does that
with other disabilities that's true like
oh you're a [__] blind guy we'll give
you PL of nachos you walk around and
then wherever you drop them that's who
gets the nachos right how Hawking serve
food on EP
Island grapes I want to know you you saw
that thing if if like that his fetish
was like dwarves solving impossible math
problems on on on high chalkboards no
short wheeel
hunting sorry yeah look this up like I
don't know I want this to be real so bad
okay it's like Stephen Hawking uh [__]
solving math problems or something this
he called him short equations
this is going to [__] up your Google
yeah definitely not long division the
hey the Epstein doc showed stepen
Hawking light dot dot dot click on the
article watching naked midgets solve
math problems
whoa they said he like to watch cuz
that's all he could
do this was fact checked it says no it's
not true ah we all hoped it was I wanted
that wow what a specific fetish I know I
did hear he liked the littles though I
mean I heard like little what a what an
insane life I know I mean yeah you
you're you're one of the smartest men in
the world you you you're in a wheelchair
and you can't move and and you have an
insatiable sexual appetite like the man
like the man lived he lived yeah he
cheated on his wife I mean the guy was
stepping out or rolling out or whatever
all the time I mean the guy was a punon
Hound he knew what he wanted
yeah my my my thing whenever I see a
crazy fetish is just like how did you
find out that was your fetish pre-
internet yeah like I don't care if you
have a weird fetish as long as it
doesn't hurt anybody every everyone's a
consenting adult great but like how do
you find out that's your fetish like
what was the process of elimination
where you're like those like those like
Wall Street guys that like like their
ball stepped on high heels you're like
how how'd you get there I know that's
not something that can happen
accidentally no usually it's something
like you know the first time a woman
like licks your ass or something like
holy [__] that was cool right you know
but that's like a that's like a choice
the stepping on the balls is like yeah
cuz like cuz like what woman takes that
chance although although maybe you're in
a fight with your with your girl and she
goes [__] you like just kicks you in the
nuts you're like wait I'm H who whoa
yeah do it again we're in a fight well
the beauty of the internet is now you
can find likeminded ball kick people you
know like oh this guy likes his balls
stepped on too we have a club yeah it
works for them it works for the Taliban
too you know got take the go with the
bed yeah yeah it's the best time ever to
have a weird Kink cuz like back in the
day you had to date someone and just be
like hey so I like this thing are you
into it oh yeah your eyebrows turned
into Jack Nicholson for that one right
there hey hey
sweetheart I like I like watching black
guys play hoop while we
Bang
if you read that book The Big goodbye
every like he would fight with palansky
cuz he wanted to uh he was watching the
Lakers playoffs on the set of Chinatown
and and he was like we're shooting the
set he's like [__] you it's double
overtime really dedicated fan yeah
hardcore yeah you got to respect that
pansky raped that girl in uh Jack
Nicholson's hot tub right uh is that the
story is that right the Angelica Houston
caught him
whoa I don't feel like that gets talked
about enough
well was from the 70s underage girl yeah
yeah 15 or something why did you say
that like underage girl not that bad
like why was that your rape that girl
and I and you were like no one talks
about that I was adding information yeah
okay also underage yeah sounds more like
it was a disclaimer man but and it was
anal I believe yes it
was also an yes the way you said yes it
was like like he just got a a question
right in a class yeah indeed indeed it
was job Mark you've been doing your
homework thank you I got a brown star
fun fact about
that fun fact about that movie uh
Chinatown Nicholson's having sex with
Angelica Houston acting with his hero
John Houston and there's a line in the
movie where he says to Jack Nicholson
are you [__] my daughter about the
character hon didn't know yet he didn't
know he's actually [__] his actual
daughter so then when it came out Jack
would be like I met
yeah I just did it for the method I'm
like I'm like Lawrence of Olivier like
it's fine I just get really into that
role I'm meta and I meta on
field wow that's a hot couple I mean
they're they're both conventionally not
attractive traditionally but there's
something sexy about both of them
H but I'm saying she's not traditionally
attractive she's not like a Heidi Clum
or something still sexy yeah take her
back she's pretty hot yeah she is hot
every Nicholson story almost every the
one about palansky I'm not a huge fan of
but like almost every Nicholson story
I'm just like [__] that guy was cool
even in that book you come away thinking
he's a pretty good dude I mean like it's
tough when it happens to your friend I
guess he he stood by him for the most
part but like what are you going to do
it's tough It's also crazy to [__] your
hero's daughter hey cazzy David hit me
up oh my God sorry what were you going
to say no I'm just like I I other than
other than standing by you know him he
comes off as like and but also it's like
it's complicated when your friend but he
he comes off like great to the cruise
great to like comes off as a great dude
for the most part the story I heard
about him was he was at a nightclub one
time and uh of course he had his
sunglasses on indoors and a lady comes
up and goes hey Jack want to dance he
just looks at it goes wrong
verb I'm like damn damn that is that
that that's a classy way to turn someone
down you ever see that photo of him uh
some guy's like I want to photograph you
jack he was like this famous
photographer and Jack's like all right I
don't know I'm busy I don't care I don't
need a photo of me the guy's like please
please he's like all right I'll give you
like two minutes and he met up with the
guy the guy took one photo and Jack nson
left in a convertible and they show the
photo and his nostrils are just covered
in white right here if you can find the
pick it's pretty great it's just like
the story of how Matt photographed the
fat you give two minutes gets butt naked
Buffalo Bills his balls it was just
matah I don't know if you can find that
pick but it's it's a classic you know
it's a great Nicholson movie Have You
Ever Seen the Last Detail oh classic
that's a [__] cool movie I think it's
Hal Ashby Robert Town wrote it oh yeah
it's [__] great town is is always
good yeah recommendation from Sam all
right my direct on the pop of it's one
of my I love that movie and I love I
mean I love there's just too many of
Jack doing coke that's the problem
that's true Peter Sellers what's the
Peter Sellers H ash oh that's the one
you love uh the not the longer by the um
oh [__] being there being there being
there there you go good
flick is this about Sam oh it's like an
an old school it's a guy who gets
basically I think it was Court Marshal
and it's Randy Quaid and he he stole
money and they kind of have to it's like
his last night it's great he's like a s
a sailor yeah and Jack Nicholson how
about we get them together and uh have
him do a podcast about the movie
currently is he still working Jack or is
he kind of I think he's retired he's in
his 80s but he showed up at a leer game
last year in the playoffs that was like
cool to see him oh uh so uh I got a
really cool Laker experience last week
uh I went to I I I I was just going out
to buy some booze at to Total Wine and
I'm just walking around and there in
that Total Wine Genie
and she's doing she's doing a signing
for her tequila she's got a tequila out
and uh so I walk over and she sees me
and goes I follow you on Instagram and
you're friends with my husband and I go
yes I am J Moore J Moore so then we talk
for a little while and then she goes
yeah if you ever want tickets let me
know and I'm like the the owner of the
Lakers okay and yeah there's me and jeie
and uh she was great yeah she she she
gave me tickets I went to the game last
week uh you got the golden ticket Lakers
Sons it was a great game did Durant play
yeah Durant played Booker saw Booker
played she gave me they won the Suns won
that one right Sons won that one by a
lot yeah destroyed him but uh Lakers are
slipping right now now how did J Moore I
mean look J Moore is a Charming guy he's
a funny guy he's got a great you know
resume but how did he pull that I mean
she she she has dated a comedian in the
past she used
Craig Shoemaker what the love Master
yeah baby
wow good for shoe I guess he's got a
thing for the the humorous she got a
thing for the funny guys we need more
people like Genie bus in the world
really rich ayses that love comedians
yes here here who are aging very well
who are aging very well that doesn't
hurt yeah I I think I I think I think
that's a and who love basketball come on
I know kind of the right combo right
Triple Threat yeah cuz so she seems like
a cool person she is she's she's she's
really sweet really nice uh uh we we
took my daughter to the game she's four
uh we had the headphones on her but she
just had a blast she had a great time
that's awesome yeah that was very cool
and uh Jay and jeie came by they said hi
it was just like wow are you are you
Lakers at your team yeah yeah yeah yeah
so you're Nicks obviously easy you two
it's it's I know he doesn't win
it's F the Lakers will not win for a
very long
time is 39 years old hey pick on someone
your own
side but yeah ad is great though that
was a really cool experience and it's
just it just kind of goes to show you
funny will get you a lot of places here
here like it know people like having
funny people around thank God for that I
know like very rarely are PE are PE are
people just sitting around going you
know we need more of it in this room
some systems
analysts but you know who could use a
comic or two is [__] Hamas or Al qaa
like let's go book us you guys you look
for
tickets not Airline but just you know
they could use a chuckle do they have
Comics over there I mean are they
pulling up Tik Tok and watching Matt rif
or anything like how's that work
something I don't know like okay so if
they started having like a live golf
like for Comics would you guys do it I
would do it like a Saudi deal or
something just like a Saudi deal where
it's like 30 million you do two shows or
something I've done worse crowds you
know you've been to Tommy te's I think
I'd rather perform for Isis than uh than
that group that'd be great though so
comic goes over there they're in like a
Britney grinder situation we're like we
told him not to
go we got to bring Norman
back he got he got the president at that
point like don't worry I'm going to get
Norman back yeah yeah it's Trump and
you've made a joke about him you ain't
coming back true I watched this special
not a fan not a fan of Mark Norman Sam
very good
points very good points I like what he
says who would they trade for the comic
is the question arms dealer yeah yeah
this guy is the most rampant pedophile
in the history of Saudi Arabia well the
Arms Dealer unlike Mark is killed so you
know
exactly I'm saying they need a comic
we've done corporate gigs we've done the
hell gigs we're ready put me in a
bulletproof vest they give you notes
before don't make fun of that guy he
will kill you we both have Jew jokes
that would kill over there I mean yeah
but mine CU I am Jewish that's true
that's true like those are hilarious I'm
like like don't tell me you are a Jew
let them just go I'm
Italian right right well that's the
beauty of you you can you're casting
you're castable you could go either way
you know Terror Jew Italian gastal
sounded pretty racist in those uh in
that context trying to lighten it up you
look yeah you look like Snow White one
of the magical
s you could work even though you're a
Jew by the way Jews and showas we do all
right actually they doing great are are
there jeos in Show Business a couple
although it is weird when you have guys
like John Stewart or Jeff Ross who have
Jewish names and have changed their
names to sound less Jewish yeah Coan y
libowitz we know you're real [__] come
on but you got Natalie Portman you got
Scarlett Johansson you got uh the other
Paul Rudd yeah some goodlooking Jews out
there they are you found the four yeah I
only heard three so I'll assume I'm the
fourth thank you
in so you guys working on any bit I'm
[__] bone dry did I try the the dog
poop one no yes you did I did I might be
bone dry cuz I was honing [__] all
weekend hold on I made you got something
oh hit us baby
okay uh premises okay this one I got
this a I put it out on Facebook like you
know it it it stinks like someone could
call me a [__] and I'm supposed to be
upset by it but there aren't really like
slurs for tall people oh and I'm
definitely going to I'm I'm going to
steal this I just don't know how one of
my Facebook fans wrote I thought of one
you should call tall people Biggers oh
oh that's great I heard that I'm like oh
my God that's so funny that's great but
now I don't know how to work that into a
bit and certainly I'm worried if I ever
[__] up the
joke well that's a good line right there
you can throw in yeah I'm worried I'll
[__] with this up but also you got the
big uh that's a friend like Sam's a big
uh you know because you guys are buddies
so um then you got the the the bigger
please yeah okay okay Biggers with
attitude dude you know but it's one
thing you like the difference is it's
like we like being called it that's the
difference right yeah yeah yeah yeah so
you wouldn't also you could throw in
your big guy peeve here because now you
can call him tiny or something like
throw it back at him yeah I don't know
tiny funny big dick you know complete
opposit right right true okay you got me
there mhm uh but yeah that that's a bit
like I want to write it I think it's
funny but at the same time I do know
that I also don't want to do a version
of that joke and then do you guys ever
get like the wrong kind of laugh oh yeah
totally you tell a joke and you're like
Ah that's not how I wanted that to be
interpreted yeah yeah but Bill Bird's
like I'm not starting to Rally here take
it easy yeah yeah yeah so I don't want
to do anything like that yeah I think
you're okay I think you're okay bigger
MH I can work in some of those what else
has the n-w in
it you you you you think you'd have that
as a note on your
phone well also is big people and then
maybe this turn is big people have never
been like really held down though that's
true except for on flights that's the
only time that's where I win that's you
win true uh what this other one uh uh uh
oh all right here here's something I
realized like okay so uh uh my wife gets
mad sometimes when when I go out and I'm
doing my job I'm I'm working and I
realized that she doesn't like it
because when I go to work I'm having fun
like my work is fun like like no wife
gets mad like you're going to those coal
mines again like like like no like so
she's mad because it's fun fun without
her yeah fun without her yeah men don't
get mad when the woman goes out and has
fun without them we're we're we thrilled
we're we're thankful it's like if you
were dating stripper isn't the right
thing but it's something about like they
job is like maybe they're but they're
probably miserable though doing that
they probably don't like doing that yeah
true you need to find something that
they like mhm but you're right we want
them to have fun but when a when my wife
texts me I'm like I'm dying out here in
Cleveland meanwhile I'm like guzzling
Patron you know oh Gary used to have a
joke about like it like he's like look
it's tough the road's tough she's like
you were to strip club he's like I go
where the work takes
me yeah there there's that but then men
have it to where we get mad if something
else makes our ladies have an orgasm
like like if they use the dildo or if
they they're a vibrator or God forbid
another
man and then that that that like
something else gives her the orgasm
that's our version of like getting mad
when you're happy right interesting so
it's like they get mad at us when we're
you could simply just say it gives them
pleasure that way it's like because I'm
getting pleasure from my work yeah and
you're getting pleasure from uh Raul
Raul yeah a guy from a TV show you could
just say or something John Ham and you
could make it a guy who's like coming
over to you're at work you're out on the
road and like some guy comes over to
like fix the chimney or something and
then she's like I was thinking about ra
I got off ah no one would say that oh
she it could be funny too if you're like
man I was uh doing a theater in San
Diego it was terrible she goes tell me
about it R came over oh that guy's the
worst you know oh yeah she's doing it
now you're both [__] lying
he he he he was having a drink shirtless
in the backyard it was a hot day he he
just kept throwing ice on his nipples
for some reason going to learn horrible
I'm sitting there like yeah and I was in
San Diego I slept till 1 it was I had a
craft beer at three right did two shows
and had thousands of people cheering for
me it was it it was awful yeah yeah it
just gets old yeah right and then she's
doing it with ra I think that's pretty
good that's a pretty good back and forth
yeah okay so yeah I I I like the Raul
that and ra Raul is just a good joke
name like like there's some names that
funnier than other Carl yeah yeah yeah
like if you said Matt Matt for some
reason's not funny not funny Gary is a
funny name Gary carrying some names yeah
I can't tell you why I I I can't tell
you what the science is but you go Raul
Carl it's it's just funny for some
reason well Patrice had that great line
where he said uh I'm a comedy genius cuz
he says uh something something Nord and
a Buick he's like a black guy in a car
isn't funny but saying nword and a Buick
is hilarious it would get a laugh
because it's a specific right doollo had
a bit about I can't fall asleep at home
you know you see a homeless guy in the
sleep on the I [__] that joke the street
you see a homeless guy sleeping on the
street he just passed out sleeping best
sleep of his life I got a $800 you know
a a mattress at home this guy's sleeping
on a
hinin hinin is just funnier than beer
bottle yes
and that's and that's better than Stella
for some yes exactly cuz Stella's kind
of a nice beer maybe I don't know who
know there's a magic to it that's what
comedy is great K is funny yeah kind of
kin yeah true unless they're three of
them in a row then hilarious yeah easy
bigger there we go come on maybe someone
bigger like only he can say bigger you
know something with that I don't know I
can figure out that joke it's going to
that that one's going to be one where I
only do it with uh when uh people have
their phones locked up
yeah yeah true true I have to figure
that out before any footage gets out
yeah all right is this stupid this is
one I was working out so okay so I was
talking about my friend he's a black guy
and um some guy was like well that's
racist and I was like but I actually
have a bunch of black friends and then
he rolled his eyes and I'm like well
that's kind of weird because that
actually a decent defense you have a
bunch of black friend isn't that a
pretty I know that's like a cliche but
it's like a good defense on not being
racist having a bunch of black friends
like look Hey Thomas Jefferson he had
plenty of
black you get it you set it up and then
the point is he was a slave owner we had
plenty of black people around the house
say you're kind of pulling it back on
yourself is that stupid no I like the
premise though I like the setup um it's
actually a good proof of having black or
not being racist is having a bunch of
black friends yeah I I I think the key
word is a bunch it it it it's when you
say I have one black friend oh that's
when it's like yeah people say I have a
black friend I see what you're
saying I see what you're saying so a
bunch is key CU if you're like no it's
not racist I have a black friend right
and you're like oh that's bad but but
but when you say I have black friends
that's like more of a justifiable okay
that helps cuz the one yeah the one is
is suspect yeah that sounds like you're
paying to be your friend right right
have you tried this I plenty of I won
black hooker you know I tried the Thomas
Jefferson thing last night and it hit
but I also really built the tension and
so when I twisted it they were it it hit
so I don't know if it was cuz I built
the tension it's a racial joke so
they're already like they just want the
the release yeah so I need to really get
the wording right cuz you know racial
jokes are tough that's some of the most
fun when you have the crowd so tense
they're like oh my God this is like we
you're on the edge
and then you hit him with the release
and they're like oh thank God then you
just hit him with that bigger and
uh it's a bigger punch line you know
what I mean I don't know if I have I I
was doing just [__] honing all over
the weekend so I don't honing is good
you got a special tap coming up you got
a I know buddy another one look at you
it won't stop damn animal well done sir
is this stupid too I I was at a I was in
a bar in Mexico with my wife and she got
on the mechanical Bowl as a goof and I
think she got kind of turned off and
then it threw her threw her away and she
was like that was kind of hot and I
thought a line could be well now you
know how it feels to get turned on and
then finish in 8
seconds you get it cuz she got she she
you know funny oh I was thinking that
the bow like threw her off and like
bruised her and then you got turned on
oh no I was just saying like she only
lasted eight seconds yeah yeah EXA I
think you should even add turned on and
then yeah thrown off and then uh and
then you're like except the only
difference is you didn't have to
apologize
oh yeah that's good all right that
that's a good line and the whole bar
left and and then you didn't have to
awkwardly run to the bathroom for a
towel yeah that's true yeah you didn't
have to do that you didn't have to
apologize and uh and the Bolding call
you a little [__] right and at the end
of the day I paid for
everything the wayer didn't come over
and choke you right you
fell all right I think there's something
here I got a couple one idea this is
something about like like do you ever
have like a memory where you're like
[__] like a low point for you can be a
high point for someone else I only have
low
points I was you know when I was a kid I
you know uh I was in a movie theater
bathroom I just had like a ton I was
lactose intolerant I would just eat a
ton of pizza I would like wouldn't
accept it so I uh I was just you know
horrible diarrhea in a Times Square
movie bathroom water coming out of my
anus oh yeah and I could see through the
uh through the through the crack there
was a a as the worst of it came out of
me a black Father and Son the the father
goes that boy has got the shits and they
just high fived and it's like it's like
weird that a awful moment for you can be
like a high point for someone else
that's true yeah well that's like
everyone in a YouTube like anyone in a
fight video they're getting knocked out
and then everyone's just comment like
liking it and like be like oh did you
see this [__] get knocked out
you're like yeah I was
concussed it's the worst day of my life
every's like showing their friends
brought them Joy
yeah yeah or or any porn star Ah that's
a great analogy yeah any porn star
that's that's a funny angle yeah cuz
it's like yeah she had to [__] Mandingo
and that's a bad day for her and then
you're sitting there like all right like
this is great like no it's the worst day
of my life it's a bad day then thousands
of boys all over the country are like
this is my thing yeah I didn't do that
last week did I no you're not I think
you might have oh really yeah fck May
when I left we'll play with that God
damn it is anything else I have I have a
few others uh think I might we might
have D we were on [__] fumes last
week okay I got one more now I did this
twice last night for the first time on
stage all right uh it's a joke that my
wife is actually banned me from doing
but whoa so you know it means I have to
do it all right hell yeah hey you're
paying the bills yeah why not so the
joke is essentially my daughter is Asian
and a dwarf so I can't lose as a dad
because if I'm the best father ever she
changes the world she invents something
she shatters glass ceilings she inspires
others she makes the she makes human
existence better yeah and if I'm the
worst father ever of an Asian dwarf we
get the greatest porn star of all
time she has told me I am not allowed to
say that [__] that's not bad I think I
think it's good it got some laughs last
night and then there was also some
people that are just like no
they yell I would play with the reaction
too I think there's some something funny
to play with the crowd on that joke yeah
so so cuz like they're cuz like they're
getting upset I'm like no that's if I'm
the best dad like if I'm the worst dad
ever I'm not planning on that yes yes
I'm not planning on being the worst
father ever yeah but then I also
searched and found out there's a dwarf
woman on only fans that made like $24
Million last year who like an insane
amount of money so I'm I see that I'm
like I'm going to start missing some
recital
thises that's a good
line yeah uh the top the top [__] only
fans accounts oh this is a multiple are
we not supposed to say [__] anymore or
not you're not supposed to I don't I
think I a village voice oh wow those
don't look like little people though
they really don't no what the hell yeah
there there's uh there's one dwarf
account and she was on some podcast and
it popped up on my algorithm them cuz
they're like you're a dwarf and you like
porn you you would like this and yeah
she made like 24 million oh here we go
yeah she's all right that well the the
it's good for pedophiles cuz they're
[__] they're looking at [__] porn
but it's still legal but it only works
if you look at it from behind that's
true the face the face is a
giveaway you can look at the genitals
only oh oh
wow now is that going to be a sting
operation Mark yeah it's a good idea a
little person then they turned around
the guy's like damn it yeah there pubic
air why weren't there more little people
on To Catch a Predator that would have
been a great bait and switch great bait
and switch Chris Hansen oh you thought
it was a you thought it was a little kid
did you no well you thought wrong turns
out
32 but the hands were so tiny yeah but
if you look there's hair on
them it's good so yeah I I I I saw that
and I'm like okay so so even if I'm the
worst dad ever ah she'll be okay yeah no
that's funny wife actually concerned is
there about me being the worst dad ever
no no telling the joke yes oh wow legit
concern what is the concern that your
daughter will hear it one day I I don't
know it's just disrespectful maybe yeah
it's and it's just like no I'm saying if
I'm the worst dad ever I don't I don't
think I'm the worst dad ever I think
you're you're creating a scenario that
is not going to happen for the the sake
of a laugh so I think you know yeah I
think you're fine yeah stupid oh sorry
keep going oh no I'm fine stupid dwarf
question I'm ignorant okay fire away
buddy do you think the dollar goes
further with a
dwarf you don't have to get first class
the house can be smaller eat less eat
less eat L you don't have to pay full
price for a full body massage yeah movie
tickets drink less drink less yes sh uh
Jordans are half price is that true yeah
well okay I think I think this is not so
stupid I think I got something here cuz
you get you get little Jordans yeah
they're yeah I I got size four foot well
that's [__] adorable little Jordans
yeah I mean yeah so that part's by the
way that sounds like a Disney movie
little Jordans yeah Jord like little
basketball players yeah yeah Mike gets
mad that LeBron made Space Jams he's
like I'm gonna make another movie Jordan
right right it's about my kids the one
that's not [__] Lara Pippen that's
some crazy [__] that's an you know what
bugs me too is that they they do this
story that is if those of you don't know
Marcus Jordan Michael son is getting
married to Lara Pippen Scotty Pippen's
ex-wife it's a [__] mess they won't
be near each other at this point it's
pretty ugly but I don't like they yeah
the joke I kept seeing on Twitter which
is a good joke is just like oh man
Jordan pipping get another ring yeah
good one but uh you know the thing is
yeah the thing is uh the the the story
that broke is Lara Pippen and uh and him
they claim they [__] five times a night
which it's like such an annoying story
it's like no you don't come on that's
such an exaggeration where it's like
it's like you you shot too far like if
if you said three or four even four
maybe night come five taking it to the
hole but yeah by the fifth come
nothing's coming out no you're get get
got break in the middle you got a pound
of liquid I
dump Gatorade on your head yeah some
stuff's got to happen like some prep
work has to be done five times in a
night right I think they may have maybe
they did it once and then every other
time is way lower and they're like
that's it's five yeah but that was the
one day they were on vacation and they
spent the whole day in the hotel room
you can do five times in a day then the
hotel room all day you get well you
don't have a job either of you you can
[__] a lot true wait is he he's a
basketball player as well no oh he but
then oh no okay yeah it's got be and
look in his defense it's got to be hard
when your dad is Michael Jordan yeah the
greatest of all time and now uh uh I
went to USC and USC has bronny James on
the on on their basketball team oh I
think like even his ceiling is like what
like second round NBA pick or like late
first round so it's like tough that like
that's incredible to make the NBA but
your dad's [__] LeBron yeah can you
imagine if there's a team out there
there cuz LeBron has said that he wants
to play at least one year with his son
yeah so the teams will draft the kid
just to cuz LeBron will sign with to get
old LeBron to be like like if there's a
franchise out there that's like need
some ticket sales Detroit
Pistons D you draft Brony LeBron signs
as a free agent you get one year of
41-year-old LeBron James but season
ticket sales probably still decent I
mean he's doing okay this year like he's
not winning per se but in ter in terms
of how he's playing it's like he's the
oldest player in the league and like
Udonis hlam he was the oldest player of
the League last year he wasn't doing
anything so LeBron's like he's still
doing well he can still get you he's
still super talented yeah he's still
like a top 10 he's insanely Rich
insanely talented he's put all his money
into his body like like millions of
dollars every year sleeps in those crazy
Chambers and [__] really yeah he he he's
like the male version of a female porn
star all the money goes to the body yeah
yeah just shows up with sweet tits likey
what the hell happen all the money is
just maintained maintain right hold
yeah yeah that that that I could see him
like like holding on just because yeah
you wants to play one year with this kid
yeah that's one thing that's pretty cool
but it's weird to build this life in LA
and then your kid could just like get
drafted by Orlando or something and
you're just like I don't Orlando it'd be
funny if you got drafted by Orlando and
then bronn's like so are are you finally
going to take me to Disneyland finally
we're in the city we're in the city Dad
we have some days off he's like no we
got to practice worst flight in America
is to or out of Orlando really out out
of Orlando is yeah it like it's all
geriatrics and kids you're going to be
pretty [__] pro-choice on that flight
for sure and tourists that are like they
travel once a year so they don't know
they don't know airport etiquette that's
kind of a a gripe is like we travel all
the time we know how to we know how to
navigate an airport there's there's like
people go to the wrong terminals they're
like could we check nine bags or like no
like they get mad when they're like you
have to consolidate there's only one
carryon they don't know what they're
doing they're walking down the aisle of
the airplane like one two three like
come on it says 9B that's it it's easy
it's it's why are you confused by why
are you stopping at First Class your
ticket says 27 you're not going to be
there keep it moving well let's uh plug
plug some dates watch Brad
special vs.com Brad Williams or you know
go to vs.com and Brad very funny guy we
love Brad yeah uh when's this coming out
do do do we know anyway yeah go go to
Brad williamsc comedy.com we got 10pm
improv club February 1st through the 3D
oh Tucson Tucson Arizona Sunday February
4th two shows Fox Tucson theater uh the
theater at the Ace Hotel in Los Angeles
February 10th that's a big one we added
a second show at the Majestic Theater in
Dallas beauti theater yeah oh and then
uh Vegas playing The Mirage great time
man that Italian restaurant in the
Mirage is [__] incredible there you
go man that was like make do the fingers
we we did it yeah it's not the only
fingers I did that weekend
hey watch out the marinara yeah all
right I'm all over the road I don't know
where where we are but the beacon doing
the beacon to at the Beacon baby that's
awesome
man oh thank I just went and saw John
Oliver there killed i' never seen him do
like a full hour it was [__] yeah
he's great he's a pro yeah uh all right
we're at uh Houston San Antonio
Charlotte Lexington Boise Salt Lake City
Atlanta Raleigh Austin Tucson Phoenix
Charlottesville Charleston El Paso
Albuquerque Memphis Mark Norman
comedy.com for dates we're doing some
hot cities come on by what do you got
there bigger when is this coming
out two weeks 20 so we got Omaha Funny
Bone Dallas the following weekend then
we got February uh 15th through 17th OKC
the following weekend
Irvine uh improv then Salt Lake City I
love that club oh I love Keith so I
can't wait and then we got for the
Wilbur for the special wil yeah baby so
that's March 7th and 8th great great
comedy venue and to film your special
there that's going to come out I'm very
excited I love I love Boston as a comedy
City too so I'm pumped it's just a good
[__] it's a good vibe they don't get
offended by anything and they they they
want you to go I asked my agent for
something uh warm and they got me Boston
in March so I'm looking forward to it uh
no I'm pumped I'm excited it's going to
be great drink Bodega cat whiskey get a
bodega cat whiskey.com it's good make
make a gold rush out of make a gold rush
delightful all right well thank you very
much for listening we love you Salam
Mona Peters we even love you Pam we're
sorry we bust your balls love shacked
sorry about the uh no we're giving the
beef all right
whoa you guys soon sorry I repeated a
joke I'm sorry I repeated a joke we we
did a bunch last week drinking podcast
I'm working on a special so the new
stuff's not coming as quickly it'll come
soon if you don't know now you know big
up Sunday's the day for my
next a bit of know the beard CL I've had
a little too much Bourbon and Norman's
talking [__] about the [__] pop and I
get down in the same
way up on the roof like a cops coming
and naked Samuel is feeling
dangerous I'm out to lunch here in New
Orleans this woman doesn't look like I
remember her and I get down in the same
way we
must
be
true